key fda panel meets today to assess a
coronavirus vaccine for emergency use
on the heels of the deadliest day yet in
this pandemic yesterday
we recorded the loss of 3124 lives
researchers recently said covet is now
the leading cause of death in this
country even more
than heart disease our correspondents
are covering
all the new developments we begin with
nikki batiste on the vaccine story who's
at mount sinai hospital in new york
nikki
are they ready
good morning anthony well if the pfizer
vaccine is approved those first shots
could come within days
to prepare mount sinai is turning this
area used for flu shots
into vaccine pods they will also have an
optional
observation area here to monitor people
for severe reactions
after they've been vaccinated we'll be
setting this up in a more
robust and permanent way as early as the
start of next week
mount sinai hospital hopes to be able to
administer
up to 50 coveted vaccines every hour
susan mashney is the vice president and
chief pharmacy officer for the mount
sinai health system with forty thousand
employees you need about eighty thousand
doses
how many vaccines do you expect in this
first round so it's everybody's best
guess we hope to get in the thousands
she says frontline workers in the er and
icu
will receive the first doses folks like
the nurses and the physicians
as well as people like the environmental
service workers
the workers that provide food service
the transportation workers
once the emergency use authorization is
approved
it's expected ups will deliver the
delicate vials to the eastern part of
the country
while fedex tackles the west after the
shippers pick up special
cold boxes containing the vaccine from
pfizer they'll drive to their nearest
facility before flying to a distribution
hub
ups has constructed an ultra low
temperature
freezer farm at its hub in louisville
the company's command center will
closely track the location
and temperature of the shipments in the
u.k where vaccinations began
this week the government is now warning
people who have severe allergies
not to take the shots the move comes
after two health care workers
who carry adrenaline shots for their
allergies suffered reactions
they're recovering well now u.s
officials are urging caution
saying those with severe allergies
should not get the vaccine
back in mount sinai mashney says once a
dose is pulled from the freezer it must
be used within six
hours time is everything it is timing
and time so making certain we get people
scheduled
and and get it going as fast as we can
so that we can
vaccinate as many people as possible
based on how many doses that we get
pfizer and moderna each say they will
produce about 100 million doses which at
two doses per person would only
vaccinate about 30 percent
of the u.s population cbs news has
learned
johnson and johnson plans to submit its
phase 3 vaccine trial data next month
and may seek emergency use authorization
in february
if the vaccine is deemed safe and
effective gail
nikki thank you